barking out orders to the lined up
masses patting them down on their chest
groin in asses blue denim packages
grabbing your pen these are a few of my
favorite things plundering iPads and
pocketing 40 acting like I am a
suppository groping survivors of masto
me these are a few of my favorite things
scanning your schnitzel your Johnson
your noodle saving that data and chain
yanking poodles a penis that shape oh
it's probably steeve these are a few of
my favorite things seeing a man trying
to plan a lacrosse
Jihad I simply remember my favorite
things and that I don't
feel so
bad making you throw away happy empty
youo taking your rights and selling them
back to you seeing good people lose
their dignity these are a few of my
favorite
things they just searched me for 7
Minutes in Heaven their budget's 10
times bigger than post 911 in undercover
test they barely catch a thing give us a
list of your favorite things treating
free people like potential muggers your
more children than lonely joshh Duggers
seeing intrusions met with aathy seems
like a good list of Favorite Things
fights against terrorists we have e St
in but to us you still give blue gloved
cup in so who do you view as the Real
Enemy what's your idea for solving these
[Music]
things
a